and i can't tell you how many songs i've
i've written and
fully produced and finished and just
said i
love this song but this does not need to
cut them out nobody needs to hear this
i just hate you saying that or is that a
record label saying that
that's me luckily i am my record label
now so that's so cool
high five so it's thank you
and that's it i think that's honestly
the scariest part because
i love i love input i think in the past
i've looked to input for approval and
i had to re-adjust that understanding of
of the people whose opinion i really do
value
around me and my capabilities of saying
i appreciate that
i i'm going to trust my gut on this
because i believe in this
because the times in the past that i
have trust me like i'm i love
i love telling the story because i love
other creatives being encouraged by this
but i remember there was a song called i
went crazy that i put out that
was one of our biggest hits it was a
massive pop crossover and
um i remember turning that song into the
label and i couldn't get anybody's
reaction i couldn't get anybody to react
to it you know
we were talking about singles we were
talking about the next project and i was
like i think this is
one of our big songs and at the time for
context
i didn't believe that i was capable
because i'm so close to all of these
songs or my children
um you know i didn't believe that i was
capable of picking a single because i'm
you know inherently biased um i i
didn't trust my my instincts based on my
study of what was working at the time
and i also believed that that's what
made a hit
but i i stuck i stuck my neck out for
this song and
and um i called the guy i was pre that
was producing the song with me
or we were working on other things and
we snuck it in
to a budget to a timeline without
anybody knowing and we finished the song
we played it for the label and they're
like
holy crap that's our next single and you
know that's happened a few times i've
called a few songs out and i only say
that because i think
those are lessons that i have to remind
myself
of the trusting your gut and trusting
your instinct the scariest thing to
answer your question
finally but the scariest thing is is
you know when you're used to having a
team that says this is going to work or
this is you know
or this is the single or this is the
thing um
and now you're the one having to trust
your gut and trust your instinct
uh i don't know why i keep removing
myself now that i'm in this position
um i have to really trust my gut and
each other as my instinct and so far
um you know and and also i i want to
have the right people around me that i
can
that i can trust as well you know to uh
to call me up or
come call me out you know what's your
relationship
to um vulnerability in your music
i feel like it's pretty good um
i pour a lot of it i pour a lot of
myself into what i write
and and what i put out and and also the
stories that i tell about it
um um i'm
i'm renegotiating my relationship with
you know what parts of my story i i give
away
i think you know there was a
relationship that was very pulling it
back
well not i wouldn't say pulling it back
i would say
there are certain things i want to i
want to protect from my personal self
i pour my entire life story into these
songs
and there's some things i'm i'm okay
with there's most things i'm okay with
the entire world knowing
there's some things that i don't feel
like um
you know some things i don't
want to share some things i don't feel
like are appropriate to share
you know there's there's certain aspects
of
of a song that i released recently that
aren't at all about what people think
that it's about but that's okay because
the song means something different for
them
and that's what i want i i you know i go
through these experiences
i live through them i find a way to talk
about them in a song and then i give
them away
i want other people to take you know
ownership with it that said i'm i
i feel if anything i feel like i
overshare because i do share a lot of
um my personal life and also just my
struggles my different things with you
know
whether it be like anxiety um you know
different sort of like
mild forms of uh i almost feel guilty
saying depression which i know sounds
dumb
but um i'm happy to share those things
i'm happy to share my human experience
with the world because i think that's
what
that's that's part of what makes my art
you know that is
have you realized or been identified in
any way to be like a really
like a deep empath do you realize that
you absorb people's energy
yeah for sure for
sure i've learned that recently yeah
it's and i think that's one of the
things that drove me to songwriting was
i have to
have a place i have to have a place to
put this you know and i have to
make these things um yeah i just have to
put them somewhere there has to be an
outlet yeah
how has knowing that shifted like even
the people does it change the people you
spend time with or
what you do um just because i know that
like from friends that have this ability
like have anxiety
which is taking on emotions and you know
that's one of the ways that it happens
it also can come from ruminating on
things for too long and kind of letting
yourself spiral
um but uh but just you know
large groups or you know certain people
certain dynamics have you seen you know
with
you know moving obviously that feels
good to you i'm curious what
if that's part of the learning
about yourself yeah
yes let me read myself i'm gonna read my
my own body and listen to my myself
you know um and to pay attention to when
i'm in a situation that i
i feel anxious or um
nervous energy bad energy about or just
you know not great energy
um and learning how to sort of take
breaks and and give myself what i need
and feed myself
because it's really easy to continue to
feed this i i like i said i love what i
do so it's easy for me to
to excuse giving and giving and giving
and giving
um until i've got nothing left to give
you know
uh and especially you know not to keep
going back to
the past year but we've all experienced
versions of this
um my version is you know i didn't have
touring i didn't have that thing to to
continue to fill my tank and i kept
emptying my tank to make music and to
you know do interviews and do other
things
and realized how low and depleted i was
[Music]
but yes it has changed how i spend time
with people and how i prioritize
my own time versus my time that i give
to
the people around me do you find that
when you are more in that space of
um feeling more that you write more
sometimes some i've had to get better
better journaling i think for a long
time i i excused
writing as journaling and it is and it
can be and it has been
but it's not always you are inherent you
are editing
you are making something fit into four
lines eight lines three lines of
pre-chorus a chorus um you're you're
simplifying a lot of
things to make it into a song that works
for a lot of people so it's not really
proper journaling you lead a lot out
um so i've had to get better properly
journaling and
and really um finding a place where all
of it can
can be put on paper have i mean
have you had some pretty cathartic sort
of breakthroughs
in this deeper level of journaling
because you know
i ask about vulnerability in your music
and yeah it's there but clearly there
was still more to be had if you allowed
yourself to go there
speaking from experience so it's not
like i'm i mean like i've literally had
breakdowns breakthroughs call them what
you want but if it's
like they're they're they're very
emotional yeah
no for sure and also learning how to
journal too because when you're
like you train i train myself so for so
long to be a better songwriter um
you have to undo so many of those things
to be a better journalist
to be a better journal whatever to write
to do better journaling
and that makes sense because you're
putting a pen to paper to write a song
you're putting a pen and paper to
journal so they feel
you know uh sort of reflexively very
similar but
the space that you're entering is very
different
yeah i have to like i have to go to a
location
to journal now tell us i mean share your
tips because there's a lot of people
that this could be very helpful for
well i had to like i had to find new
places that aren't associated with
um you know with music i've also
um been able to really reassociate
certain places with journaling like i
i've chosen to
uh go to places that maybe i'm scared to
go to because they hold a certain memory
i love going there and journaling and
sort of re re-evaluating
my relationship because i'm i feel
better and like i i
i get to actually process what those
feelings are i get to put them in a
journal in an entry
um and all of a sudden those places
become healing places for me all the
places that
that is always kind of a goal of mine if
there is a place that has a bad
um connection for me or connection to a
bad
emotion it i sort of see it as a
challenge
i need to go there i need to you know
whether to be
journal or just like kind of meditate
in a way um i i love
going there reevaluating so that those
places
become my favorite places and places
that actually were you're doing this all
on your own
or do you have a therapist i mean the
guy had at one point so
like no i get to work with an incredible
um therapist who um
actually designs one of my favorite
sort of intensives that i've also been
to
um so i feel like i've got access to
like
a professor of sorts and that's amazing
yeah so i'm i'm really grateful that not
only that i you know i
i did the intensive which i've wanted to
do for several years um
but it's just so easy to say well i
don't have time or i
like i don't wanna i don't wanna give up
a week of my time because my team needs
me for that it's such a dumb excuse but
that's the one i used for a long time
and this year was kind of like well i
don't have any more excuses and i need
to do this